okay i'm playing not laws in here and
welcome to this video let's see okay and
the nets up to 96 again accidentally
just from my from from back in the day
when I was playing um a lot of them
specially cough
okay it's waiting for him to plead you
for essentially
I think here maybe a vortex and Bishop
c6 if possible it looks rather normal 95
is that a mafia 494 trying to provoke
him a little bit why does taking at
Bishop c6 that is certainly the normal
way okay are you got an 85 I don't know
if there should be six Nets much he has
to move it again now
slightly awkward really is down don't
know II five or Bishop f6 probably this
cannot be too bad
yeah rook t1 maybe go group t8 I mean he
always has to look at that a five pound
a little bit she cannot so easily easily
a route 81 or something hmm interesting
so let's go here for possible d5 if
circumstances permit that h4 wow okay
and that's your five looks aggressive
but I don't know what it is actually
doing maybe I should do this then
prepared if I but not so easy to do okay
I also know that's not possible should
be 6s awkward at the end Miami ft 8
proves to be a mistake ok anyway
now that's what I was thinking attending
attending d 5 or 5 that's both
interesting heart the same and this is a
bit bit sharper f5d 59 epic Ingo d5
don't even need to do something
completely fancy f5d 585 i can go 55
that's not it's not that bad probably
really okay
and pawn takes most possible but I
thought that putting more pressure on
you for does make some sense you can go
Bishop before but I've rookie 6 and then
I just piling up on that porn
now lookee eight gnomes preventing that
ok
hmm weird
maybe this one startling Bishop f3
Bishop f6 I play Bishop takes a three
and you cannot take on c6 that runs into
energy for business so an awkward now
forever I don't know what he's doing
what is white let's move here okay if I
check here anyway I will I will do that
so i might as play it play it quickly we
should have six roots III just wins oops
very time morning let's check on c2
white resides Joe I think probably that
was good for white and some in some way
that looks fairly normal 95 might be an
idea but okay I allowed this a 5
business here and he's probably just a
bit better here with more space okay
this and care I decided to correct this
right here and now I'm not sure when
this distance looked interesting to me
it weakens the e4 and e5 square so I
might get something in there so know if
I've looks kind of okay right if he goes
here i have d 5 and this is interesting
it seems it's not working really this is
given as good by the engineer okay
probably not it up for the pawn but I
thought that I can just take here and
should be okay yeah it's probably equal
issue and this is what you did rook
takes putting the pressure on yeah it
should be 6 s probably just losing time
increasing or making my position even
better I could have taken only four but
ok i played this rather quickly it keeps
the pressure on them if I've takes takes
takes and queen is six winning yeah
here's no move it's really remarkable I
didn't see that before but 26 is rather
strong it gets those Bishop f3 and 94
ideas nicely combined them yeah the
engine gives this as the best
continuation after which Queen f5 is
strong the point being that Bishop here
Alex e6 is collapsing on c2 yeah why it
fell apart rather rather suddenly but
sometimes it happens okay well thanks
for watching